don't bet the empire for a pot of gold
was a quote that a mentor told me about
investing that I've used in a million
different situations any number no
matter how big it is multiplied by zero
is still zero you want to make bets but
never let one mistake be enough to undo
every right decision you've ever made so
if you have a new product or a new
venture or nor thing that you're gonna
do if you bet the farm on it you better
be right and there's no way of knowing
you'll be right so in essence even if
you bet the farm in the past and it
worked it still probably was the wrong
decision because if you repeat that
decision-making process over an entire
lifetime you will end up with a zero
because you will be wrong once